America is a constant work in progress
loving this country requires more than
singing its praises or avoiding
uncomfortable truths
this nation's racial history still casts
its long shadow upon US citizens in
Ferguson and New York and Cleveland they
just want the same thing young people
here marched 450 years ago the
protection of the law 2015 50 years
after some there are laws across this
country designed to make it harder for
people to vote
if every new voter suppression law was
struck down today we would still have
here in America one of the lowest voting
rates among free peoples what's our
excuse today for not voting how do we so
casually discard the right for which so
many fuck how do we so fully give away
our power our voice in shaping America's
future what they did here will
reverberate through the ages because
they proved that nonviolent change is
possible but love and hope can conquer
hate
last Sunday more than 8,000 of us
started on a mighty wall